Good evening I would like to thank and congratulate the assembly members who today
showed that the country comes first and with a historic
vote the law has just been approved,
which supports investment and helps generate employment.
With this same unity of Ecuador This same night the assembly also
expressed and voted its support for the national decision to fight
all criminals and terrorists who intend to implement chaos.
We are convinced that we will emerge victorious from this conflict.
Citizen and political party support is essential to emerge from
the presidency and generate better days for all.
To give in to evil,
never fight tirelessly at all times.
Long live Ecuador.